In democracies, leaders need the votes of
millions of people. Pleasing so many
people is incredibly difficult,
so democracies offer voters public
policy options in exchange for votes. But
in dictatorships, leaders only need the
loyalty of a select few,
so they purchase it with cash, sports
cars, or luxury real estate. All
dictatorships are — to some degree —
corruption-fuelled kleptocracies. This is
bad news for democracy, the rule of law,
and free markets. To protect their stolen
wealth, kleptocrats abuse anonymous
financial tools in Western democracies,
and hire Westerners to help them do it.
So how can we dismantle the ways in
which corrupt dictatorships abuse the
virtues of democracy and capitalism? We
can attack kleptocracy by leveraging our
comparative advantages in transparency
and the rule of law. A key first step
would be to do away with the anonymous
shell company, a commonly used tool for
facilitating international corruption. To
fight kleptocracy, we must consolidate
liberty where it already exists, and lead
the way to greater freedom and
prosperity around the world.
What do you
think America should do to deal with
authoritarian corruption? Let us know in
our poll. Also, let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds, and be sure to like and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI.